c'est gentil de m'avoir accompagné
jusqu'à la gare
c'est bien normal ben si si et puis ses
journaux ses fleurs et tous ces bonbons
écoutez savez-vous que c'est la première
fois que nous nous quittons depuis que
c'est arrivé remarquez que ça va faire
que 15 jours HE 15 jours 15 jours vous
avez déjà pensé est ce que ça faisait
d'Ur ça 15 jours non ben moi j'ai pensé
puisque vous partez en
voyage pu estce que nous nous quittons
ce
soir mon cœur fait son
apprentissage je veux sourire avec
courage voyez j'ai posé vos
bagages marche avant côté du
couloir
et pour les grands signes
d'usage j'ai préparé mon grand
[Musique]
mouchoir dans un instant le train
dém vous resterez seul sur le
qu et je vous verrai de la
gare me dire adieu là-bas avec votre
bouquetzm moi d'être bien
sage de penser à moi tous les
jours
et revenez dans notre
cage où je
guê votre
retour alors je vous ai trouvé une place
dans un compartiment où il y a juste une
grosse dame et dans un coin et un curé
avec une grande barbe blanche ça sera
très très bien ça bien je acheter deux
livres l'un c'est la vie des saints et
l'autre c'est
la l'imitation de la bienheureuse
Ernestine ça vous plaît ça mais comment
va vous deviner enfin tu es sûr
merci puisque vous partez en
voyage vous m'avez promis ma
chérie
de m'écrire 14
pages tous les matins ou
[Musique]
d'avantage pour que je vois votre
visage baissez la vitre je vous
[Musique]
prie c'est affreux je perds tout
courage
et moi je déteste
Paris le contrôleur cri en
voiture le cochon il sait pourtant
bien que je dois rester mais je
jure que s'il crie encore une fois moi
je
viens j'ai mon amour pour seul
bagage et tout le
reste je m'en
fous puisque vous partez en
voyage mon
chéri je pars avec
[Musique]
vous